buckle up we start with the Fox News
Alert tonight the president is now
taking major action to secure our
southern border
just moments ago announcing a brand-new
tariff on Mexico pressing this country
now to stem the flow of migrants that
are overwhelming our entire immigration
system we'll have a lot more later in
the program first though tonight the
deep state is in a complete panic mode
the walls are closing in we are now only
days away as we've been told by the
Attorney General from the release of
major documents exposing the corruption
at the highest levels of our government
now remember the Attorney General said
that he expects the Inspector General
Horowitz to report on FISA abuse any day
and then of course we have the other
four devastating buckets that we keep
talking about exposing what is the real
election scandal to one robin election
and secondly undermine a duly elected
president but first as we told you last
night the Russia hoax it's dead it is
buried it's non-existent and by the way
just hours after his nine and a half
minute statement fueling Democrats hopes
once again of impeachment and more
hysteria and breathless reporting well
robert muller has now already backtrack
because last night the Department of
Justice and the special counsel they
actually had to release a joint
statement to correct what Muller said in
other words Muller needed to walk back
everything he said yesterday in a
dramatic fashion because he totally
contradicted everything that he'd been
saying now clarification well it wasn't
exactly that but it said this but for
the OLC office a legal counsel opinion
that Muller would have found the
president obstructed justice while the
statement entirely consistent with the
Attorney General's previous remarks in
spite of the media mobs coverage
remember Barr said that Robert Muller
told him over and over again and
numerous other people heard it and
explaining just weeks ago Muller stated
three times to us in that meeting that
he emphatically was not saying
that but for the Office of Legal Counsel
opinion he would have found obstruction
in other words the Justice Department
policy of whether you can or cannot
indict a sitting president was never an
issue period what does this mean as the
Attorney General bar said today Muller
could have reached the conclusion as to
whether there was any criminal activity
but he chose not to take a look I
personally felt he could have reached
the decision in your view he could have
reached a conclusion right he could have
reached the conclusion the opinion says
you cannot indict a president while he's
in office but he could have reached a
decision as to whether it was criminal
activity but he had his reasons for not
doing it which he explained and I'm not
going to you know argue about those
reasons but when he didn't make a
decision the Deputy Attorney General rod
Rosen Stein and I felt it was necessary
for us as the head of the department to
reach that decision so the Attorney
General and by the way that's because
Democrats like Jerry Nadler wanted to
get rid of the old Independent Counsel
statute that means the Attorney General
is the final arbiter he's made up his
mind along with the Deputy Attorney
General Rod Rosenstein and the
nonpartisan office of legal counsel they
were all crystal clear for the media mob
let me spell it out for you
zero findings that the president
obstructed justice none and by the way
it had nothing to do with some Justice
Department policy not because of a legal
constitutional restriction because there
was no evidence now make no mistake this
is no cover-up no case against the
president no collusion no underlying
crime no intent no instruction in other
words the opposite of Hillary but of
course the radical extreme socialist
Democrats the rage Trump media mob
well they refused to focus in on the
truth on this major issue ask yourself
this why didn't the media mob report
with the same intensity the release of
the clarifying remarks of robert muller
after he botched it yesterday morning
why didn't
they put the same passion in as they did
the nine and a half minutes of Robert
Muller here's another question why are
they so lazy so predictable so partisan
why are they fake news why do they feign
moral outrage and then purposely fail to
tell their viewers as little as they are
the truth how did they become so
partisan how did it become so political
so corrupt that they just refused to
answer simple questions and inform their
viewers the clarification of Muller was
massive the correction was massive so
why do they choose to continue to peddle
another round of Lies and conspiracy
theories and advance their hoaxes yet
again why do they choose to act as
partisan hacks instead of serious
journalists by the way 99.9% of
newsrooms in America they all got it
wrong it was the talk show hosts people
like us yeah we do straight news we do
investigative reports we do opinion but
we're honest about it and even sports
and culture they say they are objective
they're anything but but why are they
choosing to put fake news narratives
over the facts after two plus years of
line and choosing to relentlessly smear
slander besmirched anybody who dares to
question their lack of ethics and now
objectivity look at this tonight the New
York Times they are now scared taking
notice and they're realizing oh they've
been duped by the conspiracy TV media
mob look at this new report New York
Times is warning editors and reporters
against appearing on primetime shows on
fake news CNN and conspiracy TV MSNBC
now why would the New York Times you
know not go on their favorite programs
who refused by the way to ask tough
questions to begin with like did Robert
Muller forget his previous statements
and yesterday's remarks or did he
intentionally muddy the waters to fuel
the Democrats unrelenting impeachment
rage psychosis well now the president is
standing strong not letting himself
punching-bag taking direct aim at the
former special counsel as he should and
his partisan witch hunt let's take a
look
Robert mother should have never been
chosen because he wanted the FBI job and
he didn't get it and the next day he was
picked as special counsel so you tell
somebody I'm sorry you can't have the
job and then after you say that he's
going to make a ruling on your does it
work that way
I think Butler is a true never jumper
he's somebody that dislikes Donald Trump
and despite 40 million dollars 18 Trump
haters including people that work for
Hillary Clinton and some of the worst
human beings on earth they got nothing
it's pretty amazing now the president he
didn't stop there calling out the
special counsel more for a conflict of
interest writing quote Robert Muller
came to the Oval Office seeking to be
named a director of the FBI he had
already been in that position for 12
years I told him no the next day he was
named special counsel a total conflict
of interest the president's right but
here's the big takeaway from all of this
Robert Muller I am Telling You is scared
to death to testify
why because he'd have to answer real
tough questions from people like
congressman Jim Jordan congressman mark
meadows congressman Devin Nunez and
others and by the way Devin Nunez will
be here in just moments he would be
afraid to answer questions like mr.
Muller when did you know that there was
no collusion and by the way if you had
all this time to investigate Ferrer of
violations and taxi medallions and loan
applications and decades-old tax returns
how did you not have any time to
investigate the origins of Hillary
Clinton's dirty Russian dossier that was
used to commit a premeditated fraud on
the FISA Court undermine a duly elected
president after an attempt to steal an
election oh and of course disseminate
the Russian lies to the American people
and then spy on the Trump campaign which
is the New York Times reported that
dossier was likely
Russian disinformation from the very
beginning and by the way mr. Malla why
did you hire a team of partisan
Democrats not a single Republican donor
he couldn't find one no one why would
you ever hire a guy your pit bull by the
name of Andrew Weissman a guy who has a
horrific history of abuse of power
remember Sidney Powell's book license to
lie withholding exculpatory evidence
Weissman was that Hillary Clinton's
election night party that never happened
why would you hire the Clinton
Foundation Attorney Jeanie Wray in a
case like this remember Muller had a
wide mandate how did he in good faith
ignored the single biggest abuse of
power corruption scandal in modern
political history which by the way had
to do with Russian lies and their
attempt to steal an election in 2016
well now judicial watch's tom Fitton he
is fighting back in a huge way tonight
he is calling for action on Muller's
attack on the rule of law for turning it
on its head and abandoning long-held
prosecutorial norms and by the way don't
forget about his cozy relationship with
that super patriot James Comey didn't
like smelly Walmart shoppers that like
Trump like us and of course the hate
Trump Democrats they don't seem to care
they're still relying on the same lies
the same smearing the same besmirched
meant it happens every single second of
every single minute of every single hour
of every single day why because they're
on a mission they want to take this
president down at all costs it doesn't
matter how great a job he's doing it
wouldn't matter if he cured cancer to
make every single waking moment a public
trial against the president a president
has not only been successful but under
the worst conditions that any president
has ever had to start their presidency
under regardless of facts truth reality
people that have no agenda to make us
more safe more prosperous more secure as
any Democrat talked about that recently
they have no plans for America's future
for our kids or grandkids they have no
plan to grow the economy create jobs
make us energy independent no plan to
solve the crisis at our
no plan to make us stronger abroad and
then you got this pathetically weak
field of 20/20 radicals they spend their
time incoherently rambling about how
much they hate the president and the new
green deal that will eliminate let's see
the combustion engine oil and gas cows
and airplanes she can't wait and
everything else will be free now their
collusion hoax is dead it is finished in
spite of all the noise you hear it's
done four separate investigations four
and all of them found the FBI nine month
investigation house Intel investigation
bipartisan Senate investigation and the
Muller report for them no conspiracy
collusion and we now know from mr.
molars retraction absolutely no
consideration of the Department of
Justice policy as it relates to whether
you can or cannot indict a sitting
president